so the propaganda games continue from
the white house they've now released a
video where it is all but completely
obvious that a violent cough by donald
trump has been edited
out of the video and done really poorly
this is part of the propaganda campaign
that they've been waging
since donald trump went to walter reed
hospital very quickly
they sat trump in front of a camera they
had him deliver what they claimed was a
one-take
very powerful four-minute video proving
how well he's doing and how strong he is
but it became immediately obvious
that at least at one point in this video
there is what appears to be
a jump cut something appears to be just
cut out
and donald trump looks to be gagging
when it is done and the only logical
conclusion we can reach is that trump
coughing was removed from the video so
this is i i acknowledge this is tough
for our audio audience you can find the
video on my twitter
i'm gonna first play the whole thing for
you and you'll notice that at the word
therapeutics
you hear something weird and you see
donald trump look almost like he's
gagging or dry heaving
but it's very very quick and it appears
to be a cough that was removed
if you look closely you'll also see
trump's fingers
jump because they did a poor job of
editing out
the cough take a look if you look at the
therapeutics which i'm taking right now
some of them so now let's actually
isolate the moment we're talking about
and play it without audio
and again i understand this is very
visual and that if you're only listening
it's hard to understand what what we're
seeing here but i did tweet this you can
find it on my twitter at d pacman
and as you can see trump seems to start
to gag or dry heave but then it
skips and trump's finger twitches and so
as usual the question is less about the
importance of this particular edit and
more about
the constant gaslighting of the american
people to submit
to to force them to submit to a
completely
fabricated and concocted narrative
trump's case of coronavirus has been
stage
managed in a completely dishonest way
for optics and public relations
appearances
christopher orr is a contributing writer
for the atlantic and forbes
tweeted that there is clearly an edit on
this video
experienced editors are saying that what
is in adobe's suite called a morph cut
tool
was used to remove trump's violent cough
from the video so we need to be making
sure that we're asking the right
questions when we talk about something
like this
why would the white house think they
have to do this
because of who trump supporters are
trump can't just be sick
from a serious virus that's not the
right story trump must be able to
deliver
four minutes of uncut narrative to the
audience
about how he's doing great trump must
not cough
because for seven months more than that
now eight months
he's been downplaying this as if it's no
big deal because if trump was
seriously ill it probably is the nail in
the coffin
of the approval of trump on coronavirus
handling which is already very very low
if even trump gets seriously ill who
could be the most protected person in
the world it also
goes to the laziness of this
administration
and of donald trump you could easily
cover this
by having trump stop go back one line
film it from a different angle like from
the side for example it would look like
a dramatic
filmmaking decision and no one would be
the wiser but they insist
or trump insists or trump is refusing to
redo it they insist on doing the one
take
and then cutting it out cutting the
cough out it is the most
childish stage managing that we've seen
not only
immoral to keep gaslighting the american
people about his condition
but also done in a very unprofessional
way it's a very childish
obvious detectable manner this is what
we've gotten handed to us
and this administration i guess thought
they could get away with it
they didn't and they still think that
they're going to get away with getting
this man re-elected
they may be right they may be wrong they
may be right it is ultimately up to us
to make sure that it doesn't happen and
that is why
none of this means anything other than
go and vote there is no no every news
story
oh there's a conflict in armenia oh
trump's cutting out a cough from his
video
oh joe biden tested negative for
coronavirus a third time fortunately he
did
as of today it all means you go and you
vote
it all means you go to vote.org and you
figure out
am i voting early in person am i voting
by mail
am i voting on november 3rd if so where
what are the rules
can somebody tell me that i need to get
out of line what what exactly
is the plan that's all that we have to
do we hear oh trump's attacking china
again
we gotta vote that is the one answer
here
i'm really excited that uh one of our
sponsors today
is helix sleep i sleep on a helix
mattress at home
i absolutely love it and that's why i
reached out to them about sponsoring the
david pakman show
buying a mattress in the past was always
a huge guessing game for me
i didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like
but helix has a sleep quiz on their
website you tell them your body type
your sleeping position
your back pain issues you might have and
their
tool matched me with a mattress that is
perfect
for me it's cool enough at night it's
the right firmness
i generally just do way better sleeping
these days because of the mattress helix
was awarded
number one best overall mattress for the
last two years
by both gq and wired magazine it is well
deserved i can tell you first
hand every helix mattress comes with a
10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights
and they will even come pick it up at
your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video